[MUSIC PLAYING]
DARREN KRAHN: Welcome everyone.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Darren.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
I work on Android
Things security.
Today I want to talk
about our approach
to security with Android
Things and why we
think it can make a difference.
I'm going to give a
little bit of background.
If you've been to some of the
other Android Things talks,
you've probably already
heard some of this.
But in case anyone that
hasn't, one of the things
we're doing is we're
doing a SoM architecture.
SoM is a System on Module.
It's a little board.
And it has all the
core components
that you need to
run Android Things.
So it'll have your processor,
your memory, your flash,
your Wi-Fi, Bluetooth
controller, and so forth.
And the idea is that we support
some finite number of SoMs,
a relatively few number.
And then when you build a
product in Android Things,
you pick one of these
SoMs, and the idea
being that we can push
updates to the SoMs--
a smaller number of SoMs--
and that can fan out to a much
larger number of products,
and we can reduce the
overhead that way.
So when I say SoM,
that's what I mean.
It's in pictures up
here on the slide.
Now the other concept
that I want to introduce
is Developer Console.
And that's something
that doesn't exist now,
but it will exist in
the coming months.
And this is a place where
developers can go and manage
their devices.
They can manage updates to
their devices and so forth.
And they'll have an account with
Google Android Things Developer
Console.
So our core strategy is to
build the security features
into the platform, to
have them on by default,
and to maintain them over time.
We want Google to be
running the infrastructure
and to take that
heavy lifting off
of developers so they don't need
to have that additional cost.
I'm going to talk about
five features today
that we're building
into Android Things--
OS hardening, updates, verified
boot, hardware-backed keys,
and attestation.
And I'm going to dig
into each one of these.
But before I do that, I
want to talk about why
we think these are important.
What's the actual problem
that we're trying to solve?
The main problem
with IoT security
is an economic problem.
We're not seeing so much
new technical problems--
same old buffer overflows,
same old past reversals,
the same kind of
technical problems applied
to IoT as we've seen in
computer security historically.
But historically in
computer security,
there's always been a trade
off, an economic trade off,
between the cost of
building a security in
and the risk of not
building a security in.
And with IoT, we're
increasingly and acutely seeing
a skew towards lower costs.
Lower cost matters.
Devices are getting
cheaper and cheaper.
Device makers, companies
making devices,
are getting smaller and smaller.
And we're seeing that skew
towards lower cost instead
of building in the security.
That's on the device maker side.
But if we flip it
around, there's
also an economic
side for attackers.
There's a cost associated
with building an exploit,
with building an attack.
And there's also a value
that they can get out of it.
For some hackers, it's
literally their business model.
They find the exploits and they
sell them on whatever market
they're working in.
And they have those
two factors in play.
So I want to talk a little bit
about three economic factors--
attack costs, attack
return on investment--
both of these from the
perspective of an attacker--
and then security costs from the
perspective of a device maker.
By attack cost, I really
mean, how much does it
cost to engineer an attack?
And this could be how much
does it cost with money--
maybe I have to pay for compute
cycles, or what have you.
Maybe it just takes a lot of
time, and that's a cost too.
Sometimes it also
just costs skill.
And sometimes skills
aren't readily available.
Maybe our attacker
has access to a skill,
or has the skill themselves.
Maybe they don't.
And there's also a
component of grit.
And that is how
much frustration is
an attacker going to
have to go through
to build a particular attack.
How much patience are
they going to have?
And if we can sweep up all
the low hanging fruit, where
an attacker's going to
have put a lot more effort,
a lot more patience
into finding an exploit,
we've raised the
bar in attack costs.
And we want to raise the bar
on all of these categories.
And the second thing is
attack return on investment.
Once an attack is developed,
how much is it worth?
What does it actually
get the attacker?
Maybe they want to
use it themselves.
Maybe they want to sell it.
But ultimately,
what is it worth?
And there's a list
of three things
that make an attack valuable.
One is whether an
attack is pervasive--
that is, whether it scales
to a large number of devices.
And let me give
you two examples.
Let's consider an attack that
requires Wi-Fi injection.
So to execute the attack, you
have all your radio equipment
in the van.
You pull up the van
outside your target.
And you execute the
attack and you drive off.
It might be a really
effective attack.
But it only scales with the
number of hackers in vans.
And so there's a real limit
to what you can do with that.
On the other hand,
second example
is you find a default
credential on the internet.
You find a
vulnerability, where you
can get into a
certain type of device
and you can get it to any model
built on that sort of category.
And you can just, from
the comfort of your sofa,
scan around looking
for these devices
and start adding hundreds
and thousands of devices
to your botnet.
That's a much more
pervasive attack.
The second thing that can
make an attack valuable
is whether it gives the
attacker some kind of privilege.
So if they get execution on
device, what can they do?
Do they have access
to valuable data?
Do they have access to
valuable operations?
Maybe want to
control an actuator.
Maybe they want raw
access to that hardware.
Maybe they want to
take cryptographic keys
and exfiltrate them, copy
them off, and use them
somewhere else.
The third thing that
I have is persistent.
An attack is persistent
when an attacker
can stay in control of a device
for a long period of time.
So can the attack
survive reboots?
Can the attack survive updates?
Can the attacks survive
factory resets, which
is the ultimate persistence.
And so if an attack is
all three of these--
pervasive, privileged
and persistent--
it get really high return on
investment for that attack.
Let's flip it around and
talk about security cost.
How much does it cost to
build the defenses in?
build the security features
into a product?
And a lot of the costs are
associated with maintenance
and ongoing costs.
So there is definitely cost of
building in security features
up front.
But there's an even
more important cost
built into maintaining
it going forward.
And not every company
has the resources
to build and/or maintain
these security features.
And even large companies
often don't have the resources
allocated to do this.
So for the Android Things
ecosystem of devices,
this is the effect
that we want to have
on these economic factors.
We want to push attack costs
up, like I was mentioning.
We want to raise the bar.
We want to push attack
return on investment
down so for a
particular exploit,
there's just less that an
attacker can do with that
and it offers less value.
We also want to push
security costs down.
So for device makers, like
you all, a lot of the costs
get taken care of
by the platform
and so you just don't
have to worry about them.
The first feature I want to
talk about is OS hardening.
Hardening, in general,
is improving security
by reducing attack surface.
And for an operating
system, that
means that programs
that it's running
operate under the principle
of least privilege.
It means that if they don't need
a privilege to do something,
then they don't
have that privilege.
And so if an attacker
gets execution
in the context of that
application, for example,
then they're limited
to the set of things
that that application is
already allowed to do.
So there's a lot of
examples of hardening
that we do in Android.
And because Android Things is
Android, all of that hardening
just translates
into Android Things.
When you build a device
on Android Things,
you get all of that
built into your device.
So we have permissions.
We don't do runtime permissions.
We don't expect users to be
interacting with these devices.
But we do do install
time permissions.
And it's declared in
the sense that when
you build your
application, you're
going to be declaring
the permissions that you
want that application to have.
And even though the user
doesn't approve that,
it's still useful.
Because if an attacker
does get execution
in the context of
your application,
they're going to be
limited by the permissions
that you've declared.
The application
sandbox the same.
Every application is going
to run as its own UID.
All the mandatory
access controls
that we enforce with SELinux
are going to be there,
all the kernel syscall
filtering that we put in.
By the way, who's
ever tried this?
Has anyone tried to roll their
own mandatory access controls?
Anybody tried to use SELinux
or written their own seccomp
BPF syscall filters?
I see a few hands.
And you probably
understand the pain.
This is really,
really hard to do.
And a lot of projects start
out with good intentions.
They're going to build this in.
And they get farther along, and
they need to ship the product,
and they can't get this
working properly or reliably,
and they turn it off.
And with Android Things,
we get all of this working,
and you get all of that built
right into your platform.
So there's many,
many other things.
And all the stuff,
all the ongoing work
that is done for Android,
comes into Android Things--
ASLR, Fortify Source.
There's a good blog post on
Fortify Source in Android.
Check that out-- just
last month, I think--
stack-protector-strong,
if you're
stack canaries, and so forth.
So what do user
developers need to do
to enable us in your platform?
Almost nothing.
Really, it's just
the permissions that
apply to your applications.
And then like I was
saying, declare them
only as you need them.
There's another thing
that you can do,
is if you do have
something that's
a very powerful permission
that you do need--
for example, if you're writing
an Android Things user driver
and it has access to a bus--
you may want to split that out.
Split out that privilege code
into a second application.
And just give the code that
actually needs that privilege
that privilege.
And the rest of your code will
run without that privilege.
So OS hardening really
goes after attack cost.
It really puts hurdles
and barriers in the way.
And it just makes it more and
more difficult for an attacker
to get onto a device and
escalate from there--
so more difficult to move
from the context of one app
to another, move to
the context of route,
move to the context of kernel.
And there's just
barrier after barrier.
And that really drives
up the attack cost.
It also, on the right,
lowers the security cost.
Because for developers, because
Google is taking care of this,
they're doing the heavy
lifting for the hardening.
The next feature I want
to talk about is updates.
This is a pretty important one.
It gets talked about a lot in
the context of IoT security.
And it's also pretty hard to do.
With Android Things,
we're building in updates.
And updates are going
to be from Google.
Every Android Things device
will be able to get updates
from Google.
So developers don't need to
run any update infrastructure.
We'll serve all the updates.
We'll build all the updates.
And like I was mentioning
with the SoM architecture,
this is what really
allows us to scale.
So we can build for a
finite number of SoMs
and then scale that
out to all the products
that you want to build on those.
It works a little bit like this.
So a developer would
upload their app
to their account on
Developer Console.
Google has the OS
built for their SoM.
This all gets packaged
together as an update.
And then it goes
OTA to the device.
So users don't install
apps on their IoT devices.
Developers package the apps that
they want for their product,
and that goes in an
OTA update to devices.
Updates are automatic.
We don't want any friction.
Especially when we're fixing
a security vulnerability,
we want that update to
go out to all the devices
that are active and online.
And as soon as you put any
kind of friction in there,
then it gets neglected.
People aren't sure
what to do with it.
And so for users
at least, there's
not going to be any friction.
Devices will just
update themselves.
They'll automatically download.
They'll automatically
apply the update.
And they'll automatically
do the restart.
And we use the AB updates.
So there's actually a
robustness built in.
We'll have a second copy.
And then we'll boot to that.
If there is a problem with
if it, if it doesn't boot,
we'll flip back and go back
to where it was before,
and we can fix it from there.
Updates are going to be regular.
So Android has their monthly
cadence for security updates.
And they do this for
Nexus Pixel devices.
And we're going to be following
that same monthly cadence.
But as a developer, when
you're writing applications,
the application
portion of your device,
you're not constrained
by this cadence.
If you want to ship
an update mid-month,
you can go ahead and
ship that update.
If you want to wait till we
ship the OS update, that's--
either way.
You're not constrained
by this cadence,
but this will be the update
cadence for the operating
system.
It's also worth noting
that we do a lot
of looking for vulnerabilities.
And updates have real
value when you're actually
fixing those vulnerabilities.
And if you're not
looking for them,
and you just don't
know how secure it is.
And so if you have
an update system,
but you're not looking
for vulnerabilities,
it really has limited value.
And with Android,
all the resources
that go into looking for
vulnerabilities for Android--
we get that translating
into Android Things
and we get those fixes.
So some of you may be
thinking, I'm not sure
if I want Google to be
automatically shipping
and downloading and
rebooting my devices
and updating this thing.
And there's going
to be some controls.
For the first one is
developer controls.
So every time we
get an update, we're
not just going to push
it down to your devices.
There's going to be
no friction for users.
But there is a little
bit for developers.
And they're going to get a
chance to test their devices
and say, yes, this
seems to work.
And they're going
to be able to push.
So when they get notification
there's a new version of the OS
available for their device,
there's three options
that they can take.
The first action is
they can push it.
And that as that they
do their testing.
Everything seems to work.
They can push it.
And then the update system
will start pushing it out
to their fleet of devices.
The other thing that
they can do is block it.
And this is what you would
do if something's wrong,
if you test it, something's
broken, and you can say, whoa.
Don't push that update
to any of my devices.
And at that point, we're
going to want that feedback
via the Developer Console.
We're going to want bugs filed.
We need to figure
out what's going on,
because that shouldn't happen.
And the third option is
developers can ignore it.
This may happen if a
developer abandons a product.
This may happen-- maybe
a company goes belly up
or what have you.
And in this case, the default
is going to be to push.
There's going to
be a time window.
And if we see no activity
from a developer,
the default is going to
be to push the security
fixes to those devices.
And so potentially,
that abandoned device
could still be getting
security fixes from Google.
There's also on device controls.
Because not every time is a
convenient time to be rebooting
or a convenient time
to be doing a download.
And maybe your device is
a drone, and it's flying,
and rebooting would be bad.
Maybe a user is actively
using the device
and you don't want any
jank in the experience.
So the device controls
basically-- there's
going to be an API.
And your application
will be able to say,
I'm doing something
critical right now.
Hold off on any updates.
And so then it'll
be up to developers
to actually have a sense
for when their device is--
when is a good time to update.
So if you were to label light
switches, like my kids use them
around the house, it would
look a little bit like this.
And I don't know if anyone
else has kids that leave lights
on around the house,
but this is basically
the same interpretation
we want for developers,
when they're keeping
their devices up to date.
Just leave the lights on.
Just keep those updates
rolling for your products.
And really, that's the
only developer action
we have for updates.
Just don't block them.
The real economic impact here
is that return on investment
for attacks is lowered.
And that's because every time
we're fixing vulnerabilities,
any exploits that were built
on top of the vulnerabilities
are no longer useful.
We can fix up the
whole fleet of devices
and that exploit has
lost all of its value.
Possibly, if the exploit didn't
get deep enough into the device
to actually prevent
updates, the update
may actually clean up
devices that were infected.
It also lowers security
cost, once again,
because Google's doing
the heavy lifting--
doing the heavy lifting
on the infrastructure,
serving all the updates,
building all the images,
and also doing heavy
lifting on the device
with robustly updating
devices and figuring out
how to do that in the
best possible way.
The next feature I want to
talk about is Verified Boot.
We're building Verified Boot
into every Android device.
And some you probably know
what Verified Boot is.
Let me describe
it really quickly.
It's basically using
cryptographic signatures
to verify code before
it gets executed.
So we'd start on the hardware.
The hardware would load
the first level bootloader
and check a signature on it.
If it's authorized, then that
bootloader would execute.
It would load the next
bootloader, or the kernel,
or whatever's next, and
check the signature on that,
and then execute
that, and so forth,
until the entire
OS is booted up.
And what you get in
the end is assurance
that nobody's
modified this code.
This code has been authorized
by you, the developer,
and by Google.
So again, Google does
the heavy lifting.
The Developer Console
will take care
of making sure all your
images are assigned.
Google manages
the sign in keys--
take care of proper
key rotation,
protection for root keys.
If there's a public
key that's fused
into the device, making
sure that private key
is sufficiently protected.
And on the device,
also taking some
of that heavy lifting, where we
have a Verified Boot reference
code that does the actual
verification on a device.
And this will be
running in bootloaders.
And this is required on
every Android Things device,
that the bootloaders need to
be running this reference code.
So I put the link there.
You can go take a look at it.
That initial step
for every SoM is
going to be hardware specific,
so the transition from hardware
to initial bootloader
and so forth.
But once the bootloader
executes the AVB code,
then it's Google's
sign in mechanism
and Google's verification code
that takes over at that point.
There's going to be
per-product keys.
So you don't want
some other product
that's built on the same SoM
to be able to run your software
images and vice versa.
And so we're going to be--
your keys will be associated
with your Developer Console
account.
And only your products be able
to run your software images.
And other products-- it
simply just won't boot.
There's going be
a product ID that
gets fused into the device.
So it'll be a permanent
association with that product
once it gets locked down.
We're building
rollback protection
into Verified Boot
on every device.
So a rollback attack is when
an attacker takes a device
and moves it back to a
previously authorized
but vulnerable state.
So suppose you have
version 1 of your software.
You sign it.
You push it to your
fleet of devices.
Everything's fine for a while.
And then you discover
you have a vulnerability.
And you want to fix it.
And so you fix it in version 2.
You update all your
devices to version 2.
The rollback attack would be
the attacker takes the device,
flashes it back to
version 1, reboots,
signatures check
out OK, and then
they exploit that
known vulnerability.
And so what we want to happen
is once it moves to version 2,
it refuses to boot
anything previous to that.
And so we enforce that
for software images.
We also enforce that
for sign in keys.
I mentioned we'll do the
automated key rotation.
Once a device sees a newer
key, it will no longer
trust an older key.
The Verfied Boot
Hash is something
that we're building
into Android Things.
And this is new
that we're doing.
And this is tied in with
the Verified Boot system
in the sense that at
every stage in the boot,
whatever it is that's
being verified--
whether that's a boot loader or
whether it's a kernel image--
the hash of that gets mixed
into the cryptographic hash.
And at the end of
the boot process,
you have a value that represents
the exact software that's
running on that system.
And if you can remotely
verify that value,
then you can tell not
only did this device,
when it booted, did
it run signed code,
but I know exactly which
signed code that it ran,
which can be valuable,
especially when you're
monitoring devices remotely.
What do developers need
to do for Verified Boot?
Really nothing at all.
There's going to be a factory
step to lock this down.
And after that, the Verified
Boot system's engaged,
and there's no way
to un-engage it.
Verify Boot, again, lowers
attack return on investment.
It makes it hard
to get persistence.
So an exploit that might have
had persistence before no
longer has persistence.
And so the attacker just
isn't able to get control
of the device across reboots, or
it's much, much more difficult.
So indirectly, you could say
it increases attack costs.
Because if persistence
is what they need,
they've got to work a lot, lot
harder to get it in this case.
And again, Google's doing the
heavy lifting for the signing.
So security costs go down.
And so doing the heavy lifting
on both sides of the device,
really, doing the signing
on the infrastructure
and also doing the
verification on the device.
The next feature is
hardware-backed cryptographic
keys.
And we're supporting this
on every Android Things SoM.
So this really works the same
way as it does on Android.
It's the same key master
hardware abstraction
layer under the
hood for developers
when you're building your app.
It's the same keystore APIs
that you could use on Android.
And really, it all
works the same.
There's one thing that
I wanted to mention,
is that is that we're not
doing full disk encryption.
We're not expecting Android
Things devices to support that.
And the reason is is because
we're not expecting devices
to be attended.
We're expecting them
to run unattended.
And they're expecting them
to reboot automatically
as part of these updates.
And if you do full
disk encryption,
and you don't do some
kind of pin or password,
or some kind of credential
when you boot the device,
you really lose almost all of
the value of that full disk
encryption.
And we don't want to support
a feature when we really
can't get a lot out of it.
But instead, if you feel
you have sensitive data,
you do want to encrypt it when
you store it to the flash,
you can just take a
hardware-backed key,
encrypt it using
the keystore APIs,
and you get not
a similar effect,
you get a better effect.
Because that key is
actually also associated
with that particular
application.
So for developers,
all you need to do
is use that Android
keystore type provider.
I put a link in to the existing
article on how to use keystore,
if you haven't done that.
But all the documentation
is already there
on developer.android.com.
Again, hardware-backed keys
lowers return on investment.
It takes something
that's valuable,
these cryptographic keys,
and it moves it somewhere
where it's even more protected
and puts additional barriers
in front of it--
hardware-controlled barriers.
And again, because
Google and our partners
are supporting this
in all the devices,
the security cost goes
down for developers.
They can just call the APIs and
rest assured that everything
is going to work.
The last feature I want to
talk about is attestation.
Attestation is a bit like
authentication for devices.
A human might authenticate
with a password,
with something they know,
or with a biometric--
something that is part of them.
But devices authenticate
with something
that was given to them
in the factory, something
where they can prove that they
are authentic in some way.
And that sort of
cryptographic proof is--
we call it an attestation.
So for Android Things
we're supporting
this for any devices.
It will be optional.
You don't have to key your
devices in the factory.
But we will support it for
everyone that wants to.
And a device will be able to
attest that they are authentic
Android Things device,
be able to attest
that they're an
authentic instance
of a particular product.
So this is bound to
that same product ID
that your Verified Boot
system boots up with.
So those are tied together.
It can attest to
a device identity.
So it can prove that
it's a particular device.
And so if the system is
integrating with a device
and they see that
same device twice,
they know that's
the same device.
It can attest to its identity.
It can also attest to its state.
So in particular, the
Verified Boot state
is interesting,
where it can actually
give a cryptographic statement
that the Verified Boot
system is engaged.
And potentially, like the
Verified Boot hash I mentioned,
it can give a cryptographic
statement of the exact code
that it booted with the
last time it was booted.
Attestation's also tied
to cryptographic keys.
So effectively, the statement
is that this particular key
is protected by hardware
that has these attributes.
It's that kind of a statement.
So you can also make
statements about that key,
statements like, and this
key expires in 48 hours,
or this key is
only allowed to be
used in these particular signing
modes, and things like that.
So you can attest to those
kind of attributes as well.
For the attestation,
certificate authority's
going to be operated by Google.
Again, Google's doing
the heavy lifting,
doing the key management,
issuing key bundles
for products, and Google's
providing that authority.
Just doing the
factory provisioning
though of these credentials
can be a real challenge
in and of itself.
And we also want to help there.
So we're going to be
providing a factory appliance.
And this will help
get keys safely
from Google to your
factory partner
and safely into the
device and really
help with the management
of those keys,
the auditing of that
process, and all of that.
So the basic flow would
look like, if you're already
working with a
factory partner who
has one of these appliances,
you would get the identifier
for that appliance.
You go to your
Developer Console.
You say, I want a key bundle
for this particular product.
You would have to enter
that appliance ID.
You would download that bundle.
And that bundle
would be encrypted.
And it can only be decrypted
by that particular appliance
that you identified.
And so then you send that bundle
off to your factory partner.
And they know how to take it
take care of it from there.
So again, I mentioned
it was optional.
And it is.
But there is going to
be some cases where
if you're integrating
with certain applications,
if you're integrating with
Cash or with Assistant,
those keys are going
to be mandatory,
just because you need to
work in that ecosystem.
The last thing that
we're supporting
is anonymous attestation.
I don't know if anyone's
familiar with direct anonymous
attestation.
It's a cryptographic
mechanism that
is a little bit like
asymmetric cryptography,
if you're familiar with
that, where you have
a public and a private key.
But in this case,
you have a public key
and you have a set
of private keys.
And they're all bound
to that same public key.
And so what happens is when
you verify a signature,
there's no way to tell
which private key it was.
So you get this attestation
of group membership.
You don't get a side
effect of identity.
And sometimes this
can work really well.
If you need to do some
kind of attestation
in an ecosystem, where they
don't need the exact identity,
then it's nice not to pass that
along when it's not needed.
And you can do an
anonymous attestation.
And so this will be really
good in some cases, where
you want to keep that privacy.
But there's also cases where
you want that identity.
For example, if you're
a large enterprise,
you're managing a large
fleet of IoT devices,
you're monitoring them.
You want to know exactly
which device is which.
And you want that attestation
of identity, if you can get it.
And so we want to
support that flexibility,
and so we're supporting
both mechanisms.
I put a little bit of code up.
I don't know if
anyone's actually
ever coded with this
kind of thing in Android.
There's basically
one method that you
need to put in your
key pair generator.
All of this slide is
pretty standard code,
except for that set attestation
challenge method in the middle.
And that's what
really tells a system
you want an attestation
certificate chain for this key.
And it'll issue one, if you
give it a non-null attestation
challenge.
So that challenge
value can be anything.
Here I just have an
empty byte array.
But this challenge value
will go into the certificate.
So if you want to bind it with
some other system that you want
integrate with , there could be
something really valuable that
you can put into
that challenge--
valuable as a binding token.
And then at the end, when
you get the certificate
chain for that key, that's
going to be full certificate
chain that'll root up to
the Google attestation CA.
There's one more thing I
wanted to remind developers
to do when they're
working with attestation,
and that is to use the key.
There can be a temptation
to generate this key,
get the certificate chain, and
then just validate that chain,
or send that certificate
off to someone,
and get them to validate it.
But the real value comes
in when you actually
use that key, when you use it
say, in a TLS client author,
or use it to
connect to your VPN,
or use it to engage in
some other protocol.
That's what you get the real
value out of the attestation.
So don't forget to use the key.
So attestation
doesn't really make
it harder to attack a device.
It has more to do
with how devices
interact with each
other and with the cloud
or with other services.
And again, it's really
just cost driven down,
because Google is doing a
lot of this heavy lifting.
So a quick summary--
security is built in.
And we're taking care
of the infrastructure
and we're doing the heavy
lifting on OS hardening,
heavy lifting on
updates, heavy lifting
on Verified Boot,
hardware-backed keys,
and attestation.
So that's all I
have for you today.
I want feedback so please
come and talk to me.
I'm going to be in the office
hours, which is today at 1:30,
in the office hours tent.
And check out our Google+
community, g.ceo/iotdev.
And if you want to go
started with Android Things--
developer.android.com/things
is the right place to go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]